ants make bridges and Towers to like get
ants make rope basically 100 coyotes
making
ladder it's over for us jump over walls
though they're like pretty
all right something really spooky is
happening off of the Iberian Coast do
you know what the Iberian Coast is
because when I read that I didn't know
it's like Spain and Portugal yes what
the [__] I was thinking Iberia Iberia
what's that by the coast I would have
been on Iberia yeah me too sounds
unbelievable something really really
spooky is happening with the whales do
you know what it is I know uh yeah it's
these it's the orcas so the killer
whales for some weird reason it it
appears to be that they are teaching
each other how to sink boats
there's footage of like guys in like
fishing boats the small little speed
boats and then the killer whales are
just following them like dolphins right
next to them and they're trying to go in
and like Bam put their body on top dude
have you seen them kill dolphins it's
gangster crazy it's pretty sadistic
they're really smart really really smart
they're gangsters and it's so methodical
right it's like it's kind of really
scary so imagine they're doing that's a
boat it looks like they're toying with
their prey kind of deals yeah have you
guys seen them trying to kill a seal
so there's one where it's like a seal
within the water and then though it's
chasing after the seal so the seal jumps
out of the water onto the snow and then
so now it's like watering on the snow
the killer whales go underneath the snow
and start swimming like this so it
breaks up the snow so like now the snow
is like rocking and turning into pieces
and now the seal is stuck on like a
little piece of snow and it has to go
back in the water and then that's when
it comes and kills it like they know how
to strategize it surrounders kill whales
too so there's hundreds of different
accounts of this happening and the tech
the tactic is all the same where the
it'll be like one uh in the Pod of orcas
like a lead whale will be like hitting
the I think the whole the side of it and
then the other two are gonna take the
rudder out
wait get the [__] out of here plus the
ship yeah it's the same technique so
it's tough they're saying that one like
ring leader was teaching a group and
then they'll teach each other and
they've identified which one it is wow
they like named it and everything but
apparently does that have a cool name
the theory I don't think it's that cool
damn it that's crazy because it wasn't
meant to have a killer name they didn't
I don't think it would be a killer
Lionel the leader I think this is like
Albert or something do you think this is
part of like mother nature fighting back
against us for what we're doing to the
planet and [__] because I was watching a
video recently or a bear ordered a pizza
the bear had the pizza delivered to a
home and then the bear consumed the
pizza delivery whoa that sounds so made
up there's no need pizza
damn
it's like Uber Eats you're not gonna
even believe what just happened
I'm telling you it's like the Bears are
just ordering people to eat but they
know that little hat wow what a hat
so to answer your question the name of
that Orca is white Gladys and the theme
the theory is that they believe white
Gladys experienced some kind of Trauma
from being hit by a boat or something
and decided to like fight back and the
other orcas saw it and are thinking like
that's pretty tight they thought it was
a teachable moment
so they think now it went viral this
craze of sinking is the captain blind
and he has two scars over his eyes he's
like Moby Dick he's like we learned he's
like they're coming for us and they're
like Captain what the [__] you talking
about he's like oh we have crossed we
have crossed the ways with the whales
they will come for us now and they're
like Captain what the [__] are you
talking about dude
yeah I told you
I warned you
been some injuries but nobody's been
killed like nothing's more serious than
a day in the hospital so they just want
to destroy the boat yeah they're it's
against the boat it's like a thing where
they see the boat and they'd start to
destroy the boat
communicate is crazy so we recently got
a new dog so our current dog Mia she
knows how to use our doggie door and she
goes in and out and then we got a new
dog his name's Cooper and he's a little
puppy and uh like Mia probably only goes
in and out of the doggy door maybe like
once or twice in the middle of the night
like I can hear it and we were teaching
Cooper the first day was at our house
like how to like go pee pee like outside
and um in the middle of the night I hear
the doggy doors go
like over and over like at least 20
times and I think it was me trying to
teach Cooper how to use the doggie door
he's demoing it and she was going out
and then looking like are you gonna
follow me are you gonna stay inside and
so she probably came back inside go okay
let's go and she goes back out and like
are you gonna follow me because that's
what the Rhythm sounded like yeah how is
Mia to Cooper is it is it pretty cute
it's really cute that's cute they love
each other the day day one they've
already already been like sleeping with
each other like girl though so there's a
there's different theories on this one
is that it's actually not likely that
they're trying to teach each other to do
this to hurt anybody they think it's fun
yeah they said it's more likely it's
just a form of play and they don't even
see it as like rough houses they're not
eating the people falling off no they're
not they're not doing that but also they
said that this happens a lot in nature
where animals kind of take on this trend
and then they just stop doing it it's a
viral challenge it's like eating ice
cream in the store and putting it it's a
Blackout Challenge yeah there's like a
tick tock for dolphins yeah yeah exactly
yeah so they're not worried they just
think like oh you could just die out
milk jug I don't know if I imagined this
or I actually read it but I thought it
was like some baby orca got hurt by a
Rudder or something and then it was a
Revenge thing
oh I mean it says the traumatized Orca
was white Gladys I like The Milk Jug one
where they smash The Milk Jug on the
ground but only if it's a mom and pop
store if it's like a big box store like
it's not as funny yeah it's not because
they have insurance yeah yeah yeah but
like seeing the mom and pop like know
that they have to clean it all the [__]
up ones that work there that's what
kills me Korean owned that's so good
it's my favorite yeah they yeah they
think they they really narrowed it down
to being white Gladys white Gladys I
guess that's the one why white Gladys
huh that's an interesting name I feel
like she has a bigger backstory it's a
girl I assume Gladys she's probably like
raised in SeaWorld and then the trainer
like caught her on a boat no that would
be Shamu why Gladys sounds like a old
southern shopkeeper she's the grumpy one
yeah really or Not Free Willy like some
of them think that it's like some
scientists are saying like oh it's just
a thing where one person was playing
with the rudder of a ship not person
sorry one orca and then the rest of them
were like oh that looks fun and they all
just do it it's not like a it's like a
nothing personal yeah like a trend it's
just business yeah it's whale Mafia yeah
it's business someone's rocking the boat
exactly but they're now they're telling
everyone like hey if you see a pot of
orcas or whatever yeah yeah get him in
an arm bar
I wonder what will happen if you shut
your boat off then are they just gonna
keep circling you well maybe that's what
what keeps them from attacking because
it's just that they're just like maybe
that's part of what identifies it as
like a Target or like it hears it or
something yeah maybe if it's just not on
dude imagine if you're in that [__]
boat though yeah because it says
whistle that they just can't like stand
that's like when people say like don't
move if there's a bear there and I'm
like uh I'm gonna move yeah I'm gonna
[__] run the boy's gonna try to Juke
him out they think if the rudder is not
mobile then it discourages them from
wanting to play around with the [__]
that sounds like a massive gift I think
by the time you know that they're
chasing you and then you turn it off
it's already too late it's too late
you're dead yeah you just gotta Harpoon
the [__] as soon as you see them
write it like jump on it and be like
yeehaw oh it's like you want to ride me
I'm gonna ride you that's so scary oh my
God that's [__] scary dude dude or
just have a why don't people just have
like those [__] big beach balls
because they love those oh dude they'll
jump up Chuck the beach ball in there
start chucking [__] six six thousand
Beach Boys the guys on the boat are like
having to Pump It Up hyperventilating
well [__] you know
you know those what would be a scary
thing for like let's say coyotes to
teach each other
each other's heads to get over the wall
like like a zombie crazy [__] crazy
you have to make bridges and Towers to
like get ants make rope basically 100
coyotes making
a ladder it's over for us jump over
walls though they're like pretty dude my
clients told me a really funny story
about his dog he said he he wakes up
early because he's in construction and
uh his dad takes his little Chihuahua
out and one day he heard his dad like
crying in the front yard and he's
speaking in Spanish like oh my God they
got him they got him he runs out he's
like what's happening he looks over he
sees six coyotes on top of his dog oh my
God and they're all nipping at him
they're all biting him and then his dad
is on his knees like oh my God like just
screaming and he's looking at his dad
like what the [__] are you doing like do
something so he runs up to the coyotes
and he's trying to see if his dog is
okay his dog is still alive but they're
all like nipping at him right he kicks
one of the coyotes in the face [__] yeah
and they all scatter and they're all
trying to like attack him because
they're technically [__] exactly so
they all run off
and then he [__] and then they rushed
the dog to the vet the the dog is
completely fine the only reason why he
survived was because he he had so much
fat around his belly he was a patchy
wallet he didn't puncture the wounds
like they didn't puncture
and then all the coyotes were fighting
with each other to like bite them so
like to see who got them and his dog had
like a full body cast and he was he was
like in a cast for like a couple weeks
and then he's fined out is that crazy
six coyotes just surrounding your dog
the bunch of Lion King and the hyenas
they're not unionized yeah
foreign
[Music]